質問です あの 中部経典の九十九番目の経典を説明いたします
エーワンメーすたんえかんさまやんばがわさわっひやんびえれきじえたわねあなっぴんでかさあらね
このじえたわねあなっぴんでかさあらめという言葉があります
それはこの場所で えーと
じえたわねという まあお釈迦様が住んでいたお寺の名前で
アナーカピンディカという人が作ったお寺ですよと
アーラムっていうのはお寺っていう意味
てーのこぱなさまへなすぼまーなぼとでいやぷっとさわっひやんぱちばさちあんやたらっさガハタティッサニイエサネーてなちでわからにいえな
てーのこぱなさまへな
その時 すぼまーなぼ すべという若者がトーデーヤプット
名前はまあまたスヴェとトーデーヤプッタという名前が一応 2つついてます
まあトーデーヤの息子ということで
トーデーヤプッタっていうのはおそらく母親の名前だと思いますけど
注釈書ではまあこれ書いてます
ある村の名前だと プリタガームワースの
まあ一般的にはパーリ語で
まあインドで母の名前を付けますが
トーデーヤっていうのはおそらく母の名前だと思います
まあトーデーヤプッタ
トーデーヤの息子 サーワッティアンパティワサティ
このサーワッティという街に
まあその時何か住んでます
何か用事があって ケーナチデーワカラニーエナ
何か用事があって住んでいます
ケーナチデーワカラニーエっていうのは何か用事がありましたっていうことで
どこで住んでますかというと
アンニャタラッサガハパティッサニヴェーサネ
まあある人の家で住んでますということで
何か用事があって アタコーすぼーまーなぼートーデーヤプットーヤッサガハパティッサニヴェーサネパティワサティサンガハパティンエータダボーチャ
アタコー その時 すぼーまーなぼートーデーヤプットー
トーデーヤプット まあスヴェというこの若者が
ヤッサガハパティッサニヴェーサネパティワサティ
自分が今泊まっているその家の人に
サンガハパティン その人に
エータダボーチャ このようなことを言いました
スタンメータンガハパティアビヴィッタサーワッティアラハンテーヒ
カンヌカッジャサマナンワーブラァハマナンワーパイルパーセイヤーマーティ
言ったことはこういうこと
スタンメータンガハパティ
ガハパティっていうのは
大体この人の まあ呼ぶ時は使う言葉で
まあなんか一般的な日本語で
昔旦那さんというふうに呼ぶでしょ？で
家の人をね まあそんなような感じで
まあガハパティ 私はこういうことを聞いたことがあります
アビヴィッタサーワッティアラハンテーヒ
アラハンテーヒ 悟った人々で
サーワッティ このサーワティという町が
アビヴィッタ もう空にならないという意味なんですね
いっぱいいるんだよと
アビヴィッタ まあ一応いっぱいいるんだよという
なかなかいなくならない
ヴィヴィッタっていうのは空という何もないという意味で
アビヴィッタっていうのはもう空にはなりませんということで
阿羅漢たちがいない状態っていうのは全くないんだよ
いっぱいいるんだよと
カンヌカッジャサマナンワーブラァハマナンワーパイルパーセイヤーマーティ
カン カンヌコーアッジャ
今日はサマナンワー シャモン果
ブラモン果 ブラモン果いわゆるそういう出家者ですね
パイルパーセイヤーマン
付き合ったらカンヌコー
いかがでしょうかと まあ付き合って
一応会ってみたいなと
そのように 阿羅漢果 まあまあシャモン果
バラモンね まあちょっと会ってみたいなと
まあサーワッティにはもういっぱいいるという話でしょうと
ですから誰かにちょっと会ってみたいと
アヤンバンテーバガワーサーワッティアンヴィエリティジェータワニヤナートピンディカッサアーラメ
タンバンテーバガワンタンパイルパーサッス
まあとにかくこのスヴェという若者がバラモン人で
まあバラモン人でない普通のお金持ちの誰かの家で泊まっていたんですね
まあそういうわけでしょうと思いますけど
この若者にバンテーと尊辞とか
いわゆる先生と呼んでいるんですね
バンテーというのは目上の人に使う言葉ですからね
バガワ 釈尊がサーワッティアンヴィエリティ
舎衛城で住んでいますと
ジェータワネ ジェータワナというお寺で住んでいますと
タンバガワンタンパイルパーサッス
その世尊を まあ釈尊に会ってみなさいと
パイルパーヘっていうのは付き合ってみなさい
釈尊と話し合ってみなさい
付き合ってみなさいと
アタコー・スボー・マナオー・トー・デイア・プットー・タッサ・ガハ・パティッサ・パティ・スッアー・イエーナ・バガワー・テーヌ・パサン・カミー
アタコー・ソノーテキ・スボー・マナオー・スバッサンガ
あのタッサ・ガハ・パティッサ・パティ・スッアー
その在家の人に返事をして
パティ・スッアーっていうのは返事なんですけど
返事が入ってない まあパティ・スッアーは一応彼の話を聞いて
イエーナ・バガワー・テーヌ・パサン・カミー
釈尊いるところに行きました
ウパサン・カミーとは言ってから
バガワーター・サンディン・サンモーディ
釈尊と普通の挨拶ですね
あの喜びの言葉ということで
サンモーディっていうのは一緒にちょっと話して
楽しく楽しいことを話すっていうことです
サンモー・ダニーヤン・カタン
まあお互いにまあ楽しい話をして
サーラーニーヤン それだけではなくて
覚えておくべき話をしておいて
まあその場合はまあ大体まあ自己紹介みたいなもんですからね
どこの誰ですか 誰ですかと
まあ互い紹介する まあよろしくお願いしますとかね
まあ会って楽しいとか
そういうふうな まあごく普通の挨拶交わすっていうことで
それからエーカマンタン・ニシーディ
片割れに座りました エーカマンタン・ニシン・ノーコー・スボー・マナオー・トー・デイア・プットー・バガワンタン・エー・タダ・ウォーチャ
スヤッテー・ソバニ・スワッタ・スバサンガ
釈尊にエー・タダ・ウォーチャ
以下のことを言いました
ブラームナ・ボー・ゴータマ・エーヴァ・マハン・スー
ガハットー・アーラダコー・ホーティ・ニャーヤン・ダンマン・クシャラン
ナ・パッバジトー・アーラダコー・ホーティ・ニャーヤン・ダンマン・クシャラン・ティー
イダ・バワン・ゴータモー・キン・アーハー・ティー
それは釈尊に質問出すんです
ガハットー 在家の人がアーラダコー
成功する うまくできますと
在家の人に ニャーヤン・ダンマン・クシャラン
クシャラン・ダンマン・ニャーヤ
クシャラン・ダンマンというのは
まあ善法という意味で
善行為というか 正しい道
法の道 ニャーヤンというのは道
やり方ですね まあクシャラン・ダンマンというのは良いこと
善行為でよろしいです
だから善行為を行う道が在家の人は成功するんだと
うまくできますと ナ・パッバジトー
出家にはできませんと
アーラダコー・ホーティ・ニャーヤン・ダンマン・クシャラン
出家にはこの善行為して
この正しい道を歩むことはできませんというふうに事を言うんですね
ブラームナ・エーヴァ・マハン・スー
釈尊に言うんですね バラモンたちがこんなことを言いますと
バラモンたちの意見は何なのかというと
在家の人々にはもう正しい聖なる道を歩める
しかし 出家にはそれが無理という
で バラモン人は大体出家には随分反対しているんです
ヒンドゥー教のバラモン人は
で すごい金持ちで 一般の人々にこの何と言いますか
祈祷な をやって金取るんですね
それで経典というものはヴェーダ聖典という神の言葉と言い張っているもので
その一つの歌の作品なんですが
それが一般人には読んではいけませんと禁止して
ブラモンカーストの人でないとヴェーダ聖典を触っては
その時はテキストではないんだから教えてもらわなくちゃいけない
ですから聞かせてあげない
学校に入っても他のことを教えるんだけど
生まれがブラフマナカーストでないとヴェーダ経典の授業には参加させない
で 他の人々に聞こえないところでブラマンの子供たちに教えてあげるんですね
だから今は本があるんだけど
ですから昔は本がなかったしね
ですからこのヴェーダ聖典は他の人々に聞いてはいけないことで
それでブラマン人がそれは在家の人々のために唱えてあげるんです
唱えてあげて祝福する
それで梵天に生まれ変われますよと
それは一応お金はかかります
それはブラマン人の宗教で
まあ在家主義なんですね
それにちょっと気に入らんと思っている人々も確かにいましたし
しかし少数派で そういう人々は自分勝手で
どこか出かけていって出家したり
いろいろ自由な行動はしていたんですが
多数派はそうではなかったんです
みんなまあ在家主義です
それだけじゃなくて あの出家している人々には何も良いことはできませんと
だからクサランニャーヤンダンマンクサランと言えば
この禅の道は不可能ということだから
天国に行けることは不可能ということになっちゃいますね
それは似ている言葉で言えば
この善人すら救われますからというふうな日本語のね
まあ宗教の考え方ありますね
いわゆる悪人であることは大変素晴らしい道であるというふうな思考なんですけど
だから善人にもそれなりの念仏でも唱えれば救われますよと
それをお釈迦様に聞くんで
お釈迦様は出家ですからね
エピソードから見ると
この若者が若者と言っても青年ではないんですけど
一応若い人がね で 最上階の方に一応バラモン人だけ住んでいる
他のところはバラモン人の方が強烈でしたし
サーワティっていうのはそんなにバラモン人の影響っていうのはそんな強いというわけでもなかったんですね
お釈迦様やらいろいろ宗教家がいた世界だから
ジャイナ教もたくさんいます
ですから 他の宗教の方もゴブゴブ力があったんです
で バラモン人にはそんなにすごいバラモン人たちがいたんだけど
力あったわけじゃないんですね
その街で そういうところは他のもうちょっと北の方やら西の方になってくると
もうかなりバラモン人の力がすごいと
で そこらからどこから来た人やと思いますけどね
だからせっかくサーワティに来たんだから
その修行者 出家し修行して悟っているんだという人々を誰かに会ってみたいんだと
ものすごい多数にいるんだと
話は聞いたことがあるんだよというところで
お釈迦様に紹介されたんですね
ですから もうさっさと自分の質問を出してみるんです
それで お釈迦様の答え
マーナワ若者よ エッタっていうのはここという意味で
このポイントにおいては
この問題においてはって意味で
アハン・ヴィバッジャワーダ
私はこのヴィバッジャワーダっていうのはこの分別論
分別論を持ちますと ヴィバッジャっていうのは物事を分析するっていう意味なんですね
分別ですね だいたい仏教っていうのは分別論というか
分析論なんですね そのまま合成したものはそのままはい
その通りやということはまるっきりない
で 全て分解して分解して
徹底的に分解する で それでないと答えが出てこないんですよ
例えば弁当を持ってきて
これ食べられますか？で
誰でもずいぶん簡単にはいはい
食べられますよと それはもう頭が悪いんですよ
中身は食べられますよと答えなくちゃいけないんですよ
弁当食べれば箱ごとに食べればいいんだから
だからまあそんなものはわかってるんだよ
だからこのわかってるんだよということが問題なんですよ
弁当箱の場合はそんな危険はないんだけど
すべてのものに我々はわかってるんだよというところで
そこでまあ問題ですね
例えば いくら喋っても日本では理解しないという人も
その日本語のその欠点なんですよ
たくさんことを言わないんですね
そんなのは日本人みんなわかってる
とんでもない嘘ですよ
全然わかってないんです
相手が何考えてるかっていうことは
ただ根性がなくて言わないだけ
そこで相手は適当に分かったつもり顔をする
それでお互いにすごい仲良く
このサンモーディリアンカチャンというパーリ語の言葉通りに
お互いにすごいああ良かったと
会って良かったという風にも分かれますね
で やっぱり社会ではそれは悪いことじゃないんだ
この間も人が会いに来たんですけど
会う瞬間であんたしゃべるのも時間の無駄やと
頭おかしいという態度を取ってるんですけど
やってることも全部もうおかしくて
もう帰ってちょうだいと
何しに来たんですか しかし
長い時間話を聞いて聞いて
私は聞いてない 他の仕事やってたんですけど
一応聞いてるような顔をして
でああ 大変素晴らしいことですねと言って
もうまあ一応もう帰しちゃうんですよ
そんなのは会話でもコミュニケーションでもなんでもない
ただの時間の無駄なんですね
それで全てのものは会議まで会議までそういう風に御挨拶で終わるというのはね
これではうまくいかないんですよ
だからこの ああ分かっているんだと
みんなという態度 態度というか立場っていうのは
もうコミュニケーション成り立たなくなりますし
もう好き勝手に互いの自分の主観の中で好き勝手な誤解して終わってしまうんですね
まあそういうことだから
気をつけなくてはいけないんですよ
だからそれ訓練もしなくちゃいけないし
この訓練というのは思考の訓練で
この認識の訓練で そういう訓練していないと頭はしっかりしません
ですから 弁当食べますかというはい
食べますよっていうのは食べられますよっていうのは答えではありません
だから 質問の中身をね
ちゃんと理解して で 返事出すべきなんですね
例えば はいに答えるべきか
いいえで答えるべきかというと
質問丸ごとはいですか
丸ごといいえですか それだったらちゃんと簡単にYESかNOか答えられますね
しかし 丸ごとはいでもなく
いいえでもない場合あるんですね
その時は日本人はへへと言って止まるかもしれませんだけど
でもそれは良くないんですよ
それは頭が悪いということになるんですよ
それでその質問自体 その中身を明確にもう分析して
はいに答えると 部分にははいといいえと答える分にはいいえと答えちゃうと
そちら答えがしっかり成り立ってるんですね
そういうことで 仏教は大体はヴィバッジャ・ワーダ
ヴィバッジャっていうのは分ける
分別するという ワーダっていうのは
それは論として 立場として持っている
だから分別論なんですよ
お釈迦様は堂々と私はその時点では分別論者ですよと言うんですね
ナーハンエッタ・エーカンサ・ワーダ
エーカンサっていうのは極端に答える人っていう
もうまあ分別論の反対なんですね
決定を説く者ではありませんと
いわゆる決定的に喋るわけではないんですね
そこでこの若者が 在家の人しか善たる道歩めないんだと
出家は無理ですという我々の考え方ありますよと
普通の人にその質問を出したるとどうなるかと
普通の出家の人のところに行って
私たちはね 出家は地獄に落ちるんだと
在家しか天国に行かないんだよと思ってますと言ったら怒られるか
何言うんですかとかね
違うんじゃないかというふうに
いきなり対立的に攻撃になるんですね
だから世の中で問題解決しないんですよ
対立するんだから これはこの人と話し合うときも
ちょっと役に立つお釈迦様のいた人の態度なんですよ
で 例えばそうやってこの決定型の考え方っていうのはもうそこら中あるんですよ
世の中で 人間っていうのはこの理性っていうのはない生命だから
もう嫌なんですね 考えるのは
ですから 何でも簡単に処理したいんですよ
本よりは漫画読みたいというふうな態度なんですね
本を読むと いろいろ頭考えさせなくちゃいけないしね
漫画だったら考えずまあ済んでしまっちゃうんですね
それで何も知識としては得られなくなっちゃうし
やっぱりそんな感じで
どんな人間でもやっぱり考えることは嫌なんです
そういうわけで理性も嫌なんですよ
信仰みたいなことはすっごい性格的に好きなんです
誰かが決めてくれと それで私はその通りにやると
そういう生き方するんですね
で それにもこの経典で一応ケチつけてますけどね
決めてくれということにも
で そういうわけで世の中であるのはこの決定論ばっかしなんですよ
そこで皆様の役に立つためにいくつかの例を出しますけど
例えばキリスト教の方々に聞いてみれば
キリスト教こそ正しくて
他宗教は全部間違ってると
悪魔の教えやと というと決定的なことで
そこでキリスト教以外の人々は
あんた方何言うんですかといって
キリスト教に対して攻撃してくると
その二つとも決定論者ですね
その場合は それでイスラム教も同じことで
アッラーこそ唯一の神であって
彼らこそ正しく神を信仰している
前も神の言葉があったんだけど
みんな脱線したんだから
最後の神の言葉で教えてくれたと
アル・クアランという本でそれが書かれている
だから最後の預言者はモハメッドだと
それは最後もう生まれてこない
もし誰かが私が預言者であって
神の言葉をあなた方に教えると言ったら
イスラム教の人は徹底的にそれ攻撃する
ありえないんだと コーランにそう書いてないんだと
あなたが現れることはコーランに書いてないんだと
そこで そこも一つの決定論者で
そうやってこの世の中でいろんなことを調べてみると
すべてみんな決定論で生きているということがわかると思いますね
南無妙法蓮華経と唱えることこそが仏教であって
本当の教えであるという人々がいる
すごい攻撃的で激しくて
だからブッダの教えは誰かが勉強すると
その人々はものすごく怒るんですね
何やってるんですかと
これは邪道ではないか
仏教っていうのは南無妙法蓮華経だと
ブッダの教えを勉強するものではありませんと
教えは全部間違ってるんだと
堂々と言ってるんですね
それも一つ決定論なんですね
宗教っていうのは大体そうやって決定論で成り立っ-- 宗教だけじゃないんですよ
他の世界でも 政治の世界にしたっても
全て決定論で成り立っている
で 昨日も質問がありましたけど
北朝鮮というのはとんでもない国であって
そんなことって慈しみなんかは育てるわけがないと
と決定しているんですね
まあ一応どう見ればよろしいかって
別にその方はそういう意見を持っていたわけじゃないんですが
まあただ一つの質問として出しただけのことですけど
一応それはもうちょっと激しく分析してみると
もうとんでもない国やとというふうに思うことになりますね
しかし 戦争の時は何人日本軍隊が日本人が誘拐したかと
と比べてみると どうなるかと
その時は万単位でしょうね
どれぐらい死んだんでしょうかね
日本が誘拐されてから
それはもうなかったことにする
何言うんですか そんな昔話と
我々は知りませんと というと
向こうも何言ってるんですか
この何年も古い話と言えば
それで腹が立つんですね
だから結局それで答えが出てこなくなるんですよ
この決定論の場合はね
だからそれが良くないと仏教は言ってるんですよ
何か答え出して 何か人々に有効に役に立つように
疑問が起きたら何か役に立つようにしたいんですね
しかし 人間は絶対そうはしたくないんですよ
もし私でも北朝鮮に対してすっごい厳しい意見出しっぱなし説法するならば
結構今頃儲かりますね
で 人をそうやってこの落ちてるところにまた蹴って落とすことが好きなんですね
それは落としてるところからもうちょっと手を出して立ち上がれて言っちゃうと
もう怒られるんですね
で そこは明確に世の中にあります
しかし 誰も認めない その代わりにブッダに悪口を
だからこの 私にはどんな悪口言ったっていいんですが
この一応決定論の性質を
決定論ってどういうものか
我々の生き方にどれぐらいそれは素晴らしいかっていうぐらいのことだけは覚えておいてください
自分たちが決定論でいると
決して答えが出てこない
ずっとごちゃごちゃ状態で
対立状態が徹底的に続く
決定論には必ず向かい合うのは対立なんですね
戦い 喧嘩なんですね 喧嘩
戦いから出てくるのは苦しみですよ
それは決して幸福 平和っていうことは出てこない
平和好きで しかし決定論者っていうのは矛盾なんですね
平和っていうのはどちらかのこの二つの組み合わせだからね
グループ二つの組み合わせは平和でやってるし
あるいは同じ人間の同士でも戦うことは平和がないことで
二人ぐらいでも仲良くすることが平和ですから
二人にも二つの意見 決定論があると
絶対それは成り立たないんですね
平和っていうのは だから一人一人が自分の意見にしがみついているっていうことは
決定論の世界で平和は成り立たない
だから自分は言っていることは正しいんだぞという態度で平和を語るっていうのは
明らかにインチキで世界を壊してやる人々なんですね
だから この間来た人のように
この地球環境を守る なんとかなんとかっていうことの教務をやる人なんですけど
やっぱりいかにそのこれ問題はぐちゃぐちゃにして
環境は潰す もう壊したい放題壊せるかということしか頭の中にないんですね
そのために働いているんですね
しかし 肩書きは環境を守るという
だからこのその矛盾というのはね
まあそうやって何も知らない愚か者たちが
もう矛盾を持っていて
行動する だから平和を語る人に限って
戦争に油を差すというふうなことになってしまう
それがこの決定論の特色なんですね
特色ではなくて 決定論というのはそんなもんなんですよ
だからこの随分気をつけてほしいと
というのは仏教の立場で
仏教はいつでもヴィパッサナーで
物事はそんな簡単にイエスとノー
とかね はい わかりましたとかね
私は反対だとかね そう簡単には成り立つわけじゃない
まあ私は反対だと言えるものもあるし
私は賛成だと言えるものもあるし
そういうふうに言えないものもあります
ですから とにかく物事はちゃんと分析する能力を持つ
ですから まあちょっとのつまらない質問にしても
分析してみた方がよろしいんですね
そこでお釈迦様は私は分別論者ですよと
このポイントにおいてはと
言ったところでも この若者にとってはすごいショックなんですよ
もう考えたこともない反応だから
この人はおそらくこの出家者が私にえらい抗議かけてくるでしょう
そうすれば私も喧嘩して言い返すんではないかと
私もかなりの大物で もう学問やら論争やらね
そんなプロではないかと
まあ東大寺はかなりのその点ではプロなんですよ
悪口を言うのはかなり上手で
結構口が荒っぽい人だそうです
そこら辺は説明はないんですね
これ お釈迦様の答えは
ギヒッサワハンマナパッバジタッサワ
ミッチャパティパンナンナ ワンネーミ ギヒーワヒマナパッバジトーワ ミッチャパティパンノ ミッチャパティパッターディカルナヘトゥナアーラビコホーティナ ニャーヤンダンマンク
シャランティ ギヒッサワハンマナパッバジタッサワ サッマーパティパッティンワンネーミ ギヒーワヒマナパッバジ
トーワ サッマーパティパンノ サッマーパティパッターディカルナヘトゥアーラビコホーティ ニャーヤンダンマンクシャランティ
それでお釈迦様の分析が入るんです
入れてくれるんですね
ギヒッスは特にお釈迦様自分の意見を述べる場合は
私がということをすごく強調するんですよ
その時は 一般論的な真理を語る場合は
私 私 それはあまり強調しないんです
一人の人間として 自分の見解
自分の見解を述べるときは
いつでも一人称で私はということは強調する
それもすごい丁寧な言い方なんですよ
私はこういう考え方ですよということは
だいたい根性ない人は
もう私は抜けて もうこういう考え方は正しいんですよ
堂々と言うんですね 一般論として
それはとんでもない話です
一般論は一般論で 自分の考え方は
主観は一般論として出してはいけません
そういう人々は信頼できません
時々自分が負けそうになってくると
みんなそう思ってるんです
みんなに投げつけて逃げちゃうんです
それだけでもう愚か者ですよ
相手にしてはいけないんです
私は個人的には まあこういうことはこういうふうなことではないかと思ってますよと
例えば 朝鮮人をみんな爆弾を落として殺すべきですよと
私が思ってますよというのは
別にそれほど悪い言葉じゃないんですよ
私がという勝手にその人の勝手な主観
主観です みんなそう思っているんだからと言っちゃうと
もうとんでもない悪人なんですよ
みんなもそう思っているんだよと
だから個人には まあそういう意見を持つっていうのは
それは別の話です ですから
一般論と個人個人の考え方っていうのをちゃんと区別しなくちゃいけない
個人の意見ちゃんと言うのは丁寧な言い方です
で マスコミの報道みたいに
自分一人の意見は全国民の意見として作る
合成するという それはマスコミのやり方
いわゆる現代のね マスコミこそ世界的力持っていて素晴らしいと言っていて
嘘しか広げないんですよ
全てその人の記者というよりも作家ですよ
みんな そのその作家の意見を書いたりするだけのことです
だから分別論者で見ると
これもすぐわかるんですね
これがこの人の作品であって
別に事実ではありません
ここら辺 ここら辺は事実ですよということは一応わかります
分別能力を持ってるならば
決定能力だったらもう末期状態
もう治らない 頭は成長しない
もう悪いままで終わっちゃうんですね
ということで お釈迦様が答え出す場合はアハン・ギヒッサ・ワ
パーリ語になってくると
この言葉の順番が随分違いますよ
長い文章をまとめてパッと理解しないと理解できない
ものすごくあっちこっちあっちこっちに場所を引っ越しさせてます
だからギヒッサという言葉は
日本訳するとほとんど後に出てくるんですよ
ギヒッというのは在位の人にもという意味です
アハン私がこういうようなことを言います
マーナワっていうのは若者よ
ギヒッサワパッバチカッサワ
在家であろうか 出家であろうか
ミッチャーパティパッティン
誤った道 誤った生き方
この場合は大体道徳的な言葉で
ミッチャーパティパッティン
誤った生き方 誤った道
誤った方法っていうのは
ナワンネーミ 褒めません
アハン 私は褒めません
在家 在家であろうか 出家であろうか
誤った道は決して褒めませんと
そこでお釈迦様はそちらで決定していますよ
だから何か結論出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
結論出すんだからといって
ちゃんと分析してから細かい細かい結論に行くんですよ
決定論が悪いんだからといって
ずっと曖昧でいるわけじゃないんですよ
決定論悪いと思う人こそ智慧がある人だからね
だから癒すか否かはっきりします
その場合は なぜ分析するかというと
癒す可能か はっきりするためなんです
だからずっと曖昧でいるのは決定論者なんですよ
分かってないくせにそれ決めつけているんだから
他人の意見を聞こうともしないんだから
だから決定決めたという人に限って
何も分かってない状態でずっといる
その簡単には決めないんだけど
分析して分別してちゃんと理解する人が
すぐ答え見つかるんですよ
だからこっちはお釈迦様
答え見つけて見つけて言うんですね
ミッチャーパティパダン
誤った道 道徳的に間違った道は褒めません
そこで気をつけましょう
これで間違った道っていうのは道徳的なんですね
倫理的なんです だから倫理ということは
仏教ではすごく力強いんです
ただ 何でも褒めません
倫理的にOKか 癒す可能か言えない場合は
ただいいとは言えませんね
それで説明する ギヒーワーヒマーナ
在家であろうか パッバジトーワ
出家であろうか ミッチャーパティパンノ
誤った道を歩んで ミッチャーパティパッターディカラナヘトゥ
その誤った道を成功することによって
アディカラナというのは何かうまく成功するという意味なんですね
無事完了できた 無事成功できたということは
それで誤った道を歩んで
そこはすごく無事成功したとしても
その原因で ナアーラデコホーティニャーヤンダンマンクサラン
その人はクサランダンマン
クサランダンマン 善なる法
正しい道というシステム
ニャーヤンというのは大体システムというふうな
これは論理学的に使う言葉なんですけど
私はこの道と簡単に訳しましたが
例えば八正道もニャーヤンなんですね
その場合はパティパダという言葉を使いますけどね
で ニャーヤっていうのは何か思考が考え方がありまして
やり方がありまして それを論理的にこういこういうことで
こういうことで こういう風にしなくちゃいけないんだぞというふうな
この組織思考が組織化してシステムになったところ
ニャーヤという言葉使いますね
ですから 日本語にする場合は
まあクサランダンマンニャーヤンと移転させないと
クサランダンマンというのが善法ですね
善 正しい真理ですね 善法
というシステムは成功するわけじゃないんだと
そこでこの相手と話し合うんだから
話し合う場合は 二人とも何か同じ概念を持たないと
その概念について あなたどんな意見
あなたどんな意見 あなたどんな意見というふうに
たとえ違う意見があっても
ある一つのものについてなんですよ
だから国際会議やる場合は
ある国から行った人は
まあまあ何て言いますか
自然を守ることに興味あって
他の国から来た人が あの
工業開発はいかがなものか
そうすると会議になりませんよ
一つのテーマでまとめなくちゃいけないんですね
それでこのブラマンジンとお釈迦様がニャーヤンダンマンクサランというポイントについてまとめて話し合ってるんですね
いわゆる正しい道 宗教的に精神たる道って何ですかという
俗的に言えば天国に行く道は何ですかという
こんなことで だから善というのは何ですかと
その方法 いわゆる倫理ですよ
倫理論では 善と悪の分別は一番最初に出てくる問題でしょ
善って何ですか？悪って何ですかという
だからそれは倫理の場合はね
もうこれが魂であって
命であってね 結論出そうではないかと
でも未だに出してないですね
倫理学の西洋倫理学では出せないんですね
何も分かってないんだから
で 仏教になってくると
そんなのは当たり前で
倫理っていうのは当たり前の法則として決まってあって
それから真理が立ってますからね
だから倫理論というのは
仏教においてはすごい幼稚的なところで
すぐ終わってしまいます
で このバラモン人もやっぱりこの倫理というところで話し合ってますね
ですからニャーヤンダンマンクサラン What
is good?という意味でね
良い道って何なのか 聖なる道って何なのか
天国に行く道って何なのか
人間は歩むべき道って何なのかっていう風な
どんな言葉に入れ替えたってもよろしいです
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
道が間違っている 誤った道を歩んでるならば
倫理的に誤って道を歩んでいるならば
その人には人間が歩むべき道を成功することはできませんと
これは出家で在家という関係ないんだと
言って 出家か在家かという
この形状的な区別はお釈迦様はもう受け取らないんですよ
お釈迦様は中に中身に問題を持っていくんですね
出家か在家かっていうのは
単なる表面的な差であって
何をして食べてるかっていうぐらいの差で
在家の人は仕事をして食べて
出家の人は托鉢して食べていると
在家の人は豪華な家で寝て
出家の人は木の下で寝ているとかね
そんなふうな差であって
そんな表面的な差で物事を判断してはいけませんと
問題は中身だよと というところに持ってくるんです
そこでギヒッスワーハンマーノパッバジタッサワサンマーパティパッティンワンネイネ
正しい道を私は評価しますと
在家にも出家にも 在家であろうか
出家であろうが ギヒッスワーハンマーノパッバジトワサンマーパティパンノー
正しい道 過ちがない道を歩むことによって
サンマーパティパッターディカラナヘトゥ
その過ちがない道を成功することによって
アーラベクホーテニャーヤンダンマンクサラン
その人はニャーヤンダンマンクサランということは成功しますよと
人間歩むべき道 精神的な道が
道を成功しますよと まあそこら辺でこのブラマン若者もね
まあなかなか論争というか
この対話は上手な人で
そのポイントは一応理解して
だからブラマンジンはある別な立場で
ブッダはまた別な立場でいるんだよということははっきりしますね
まあそれで次に行くんですね
なぜブラマンジンが別な立場にいるかということを
いわゆる自分がなぜ別な出家が悪いと
在家こそ正しいという考え方
なぜ我々は言っているのかと
それは次に説明していくんですよ
だからこの話し合う時は
もうペラペラペラペラ言いたい放題喋るんじゃなくて
ポイントごとに 綺麗に進んでいくんですよ
最初にメインテーマを出して
そこで意見交わして はい
それでは次のステップということで
次のステップに行く だから 2番目のステージに今入るんですよ
その時は原因とちょっと詳しく訳を出す
それでまたお釈迦様の答えが入ると
ブラームナボゴタマエーワマハンすブラームナバラモンたちがこのようなことを言いますと
マハッタミダンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナンマハサマーランバンガラワーサカンマッターナンマハッファランホーティアッパッタミダンアッパキッチャンアッパ
ディカラナンアッパサマーランバンサッバッジャカンマッターナンアッパッファランホーティーティイダバワンゴータモーキングアーハティ
バラモンたちの考え方これやと
マハッタンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナンマハサマーランバンという 4つの言葉ほとんど同じ意味なんですよ
もう大変やってみなですよ
で こちらの意味はマハッタンというのはマハンテーヒバフーヒヴェイヤーワッチャカレーヒはウパカレーヒはアットー
何か仕事をするときはものすごくスケールが大きいんだと
やらなくちゃいけないことっていうのはいっぱいあるんだと
道具もたくさん使うんだよと
それ在家の生き方なんですね
在家の生き方っていうのは
ものすごい道具 道具 道具
車が必要は 家が必要は
炊飯器も必要は もう電子レンジもいるわ
もういろんなもの必要なんですね
それで朝起きてから寝るまでっていうのは
やらなくちゃいけないことっていうのはあまりにもありすぎて
それはマハッタンということであって
しかし 次の言葉はおなじみなんですよ
マハキッチャン キッチャンっていうのはやらなくてはいけないこと task
というかね 仕事ですね
それはマハたくさんになります
マハンタイナームガハナマンガラディーヌキッチャーニ
注釈書では このいろんなお祝い事やら儀式やらお祭りやら
そんな感じでやらなくていけないことがたくさんあるんだっていうことで
なんとか通訳しようとしているんですね
イダンアッジャカッタッダン
これは今日やらなくてはいけないと
イダンスウェーティ これは明日やらなくてはいけないんだと
まあこのようにアディカーナサンカーターニ
そのように結論出して判決しなくちゃいけないんだから
マハーディカラナンと言いますよと
いわゆる仕事はちゃんとスケジュール立てて計画立てて生きていなくちゃいけない
それぐらい仕事たくさんあるんですね
ですから 時間もなくなりますから
ちゃんと今日の仕事は今日で
明日やるべきことを明日でとか
そういう風にちゃんと計画立てて仕事しなくちゃいけない
それがマハーディカラナンという言葉の意味なんですね
それでマハッタンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナン
次にマハサマーランバン
サマーランバっていうのは
まあおそらくバラモン人の意味が違うとは思いますけど
仏教の経典は違う また違う意味でとってます
普通はマハサマーランバンっていうのは
私が知ってる日本語で言えば
もう結構スケールが大きくて
もう大変だよっていうことなんですよ
ですから ものすごく疲れる
まあ一般の人々の生活そうでしょうね
会社に行って仕事したっても
もう疲れるわ だからもうやらなくちゃいかんこといっぱいあるんだから
誰かが何かやらなかったら怒鳴らなくちゃいけないし
怒らなくちゃいけないし
ものすごいもうややこしいんですね
人に仕事を分配してあげたら
それ全部まとめて仕事になるんだから
誰かがちゃんとやらなかったら大変でしょうに
あるいは誰かが失敗しちゃうと冗談じゃないでしょうね
そうすると仕事全体的に成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 仕事する場合は
もう失敗する人はもうそうさせないようにと気をつけなくちゃいけないし
サボる人にとってはサボらないようになんとかしなくちゃいけないし
もうごちゃごちゃなんですね
そこはマハサマーランバンということで
しかし 仏教はサマーランバンっていうのはこの搾取
迷惑 この拷問という意味で取ってますね
だから仕事になってくると
人をいじめることやら殴ることやら
罰を与えることやら もう殺すことやら
そういうこと出てくるということで
サマーランバっていうのは殺すという意味でありますから
仏教はその意味でとって
相手の意見をまあ潰しちゃうんですね
まあ搾取と言ったっても
それでもよく見ると人殺しまで入ってるでしょうね
現代語では搾取っていうことなんですが
搾取も可愛い言葉ではないでしょうね
それはもう人殺すところまでその範囲には入ります
そこで在家の生き方っていうのはマハサマーランバン
サマーランバン まあ大変な
まあお互いに叱ったり
しけられたり 怒鳴ったり
怒鳴られたり 罰を与えたり
与えられたり もういろいろ大変な世界だよと
それぐらい大変なこと
仕事は多い それで計画を立ててやらなくてはいけない
これでまた大変疲れて
もうどうにもならん状態にでみんな生きてるんですよ
それでも生きて頑張ってるんだから
マハッパラン大化になるんだと
それが一番褒めるべきですよというのがブラマン人の考え方なんですね
そこで逆に出家の場合はアッパッタン
やることってのはほとんどない
アッパキッチャン もうそれもうやることはそんなにたくさんない
アッパアディカラナ 判断することっていうのはそうほとんどない
今日は明後日のことだけは明後日やること
今日はこれは今日やらなくちゃいけないとか
そんな別にそう判断することって何もない
アッパサマーランバ 他人に迷惑をかけたり
搾取したり 管理したりとかね
それ全然ないと あまりにも楽すぎやと
だからパッバッチャカッマッターナ
出家の仕事っていうのは単純で楽すぎると
楽すぎだから とんだ大した仕事か
誰がするもんかと だからアッパッパラン
結果っていうのは少ない
小さいんだと 小果ですと
ということを言うんです
そこでなぜブラマン人が在家褒めるかというと
在家っていうのはもうやっと生きてるぐらい
もう大変一日中ものすごいたくさん仕事がある
だから在家の在家の生き方は素晴らしいよと褒めるべきですよ
天国に行くんだったら在家が行くんだよと
出家にしてみれば もう全然仕事もしていないし
もう判断することもいらんし
もう人を搾取するとか
もう成り立たないし 管理する何も成り立ちません
ただもうすごい楽にいるんではないか
だから出家がいい人やって思ったって大したことないんだと
というところで そこがポイントなんですね
イダ・バワンゴートモ・キンガーハ
このポイントについて
バワンゴートモ 釈尊は何を言いますかね
それでお釈迦様 エッタピ・コウ・アハン・マーナヴァ・イバッジャ・ワードゥ
ここにおいても若者 私は分別論者ですよと
ナアハン・エッタ・エーカンサ・ワードゥ
決定論では喋るんじゃない
アッティ・マーナヴァ・カッマッターナん
・マハッタン・マハーキッチャン・マハーディカラナン・マハサマーランバン・ディパッジャマーナん・アッパッファラン・ホーティ
そこでブラモン若者の論点はこの生き方なんですね
仕事なんですよ どのように生きてます
生きてますかというと
在家の人っていうのはすごい複雑な生き方をしている
食べるために 出家の人はまったくもそんな複雑な生き方は何もしないで食べているんですね
だから二人ともちゃんと食べて生きてますよ
結果はそれだけなんですが
しかし 在家の人っていうのは
食べるためにあの並ならぬ努力っていうのは並ならぬ苦しみっていう
それはバラモン人が評価するんですね
出家っていうのは 言っても簡単で
何も困ることなく もう管理することやら何一つなく食べていけてるっていうことで
ですから 結局はまあ何をして食べてるかというより
仕事のことなんですね
だからそこら辺 ちゃんとお釈迦様も理解していて
それからそこら辺で分析に入るんです
アッティマーナ・カンマッターナ
若者 仕事ある 一種の仕事あるんだと
カンマッターナというのは仕事のこと
マハッタン まあ複雑で大変だと
マハキッチャン やらなくちゃいけないことたくさんあるんだと
マハーディカラナン 判断することっていうのはものすごいたくさんあるんだと
マハーサマーランバン
まあ迷惑で疲れる 他人にも疲れる
自分も疲れる もう苦労する仕事ありますよと
ヴィパッジャマーナン
でももし失敗したら うまくいかなかったらアッパッパランホール
苦労多い やるべきことを複雑で
ややこしい仕事ありますよと
しかし うまくいかなかったら結果がない
アッティマーナ・カンマッターナ・マハッタン・マハキッチャン・マハーディカラナン・マハーサマーランバン・サンパッジャマーナン・マハッパラン・ホーティ
また別な仕事もありますよと
複雑で ややこしくて 疲れて
管理やら判断やら 与えることをしなくちゃいけない
あんまりな仕事もありますが
サンパッジャマーナン
うまくいけばすごい大結果になりますよと
大成功するんだと それからアッティマーナ・カンマッターナ
また仕事あるんだよと
アッパッタン・アッパキッチャン・アッパーディカラナン
随分単純明快で簡単な仕事あるんだと
もう難しくはないし 疲れることもないし
ヴィパッジャマーナン
しかしうまくいかなかったらアッパッパラン
結果が小さい 成功しなかったらすごい結果が小さい
それから逆にものすごい単純簡単明快な仕事あるんだよと
しかし うまくいったらものすごい大結果になるんだよと
そこでお釈迦様は仕事そのものを四つに分けちゃうんです
カンマッターナといえば
まあ仕事で この場合 お釈迦はほとんどサイケのことを言ってますけど
まあサイケってまとめて言いますけどね
それでパーリ語で覚えておいてください
この修行すると 瞑想すると
瞑想にもカンマッターナと言うんですね
で 先生のところに行ってカンマッターナをもらうと言うんですね
で 修行中でも度々指導者に会って話し合って
話し合うたびにカンマッターナをもらう
カンマッターナをもらうと言うんですね
ということは 仕事っていう意味なんですね
で 何か瞑想したところで
ちょっと何か自分には疑問が生じてきたら
指導者に話してみる 話したら
指導者がじゃあこういう風にしなさいと教えてくれると
そこはこの あの 日本語でインタビューと言うんですけど
仏教ではそう言わないんですね
まあカンマッターナと言うんですね
カンマッターナっていうのは仕事ということですね
だから日本語ではインタビューというビューでしたっけ
それが人気があって 言うことはさっぱり聞かないんですね
インタビューに行ったんだだから世間話やらくだらないことやら
もうそればっかりペラペラペラペラしゃべる
見え張るはもう高慢であれやこれで煩悩が出して強化することでインタビューするんです
それはもう仏教じゃないんですけどね
だからもう一番やりたくはないというか
嫌な仕事っていうのは
そのインタビューというやつなんですね
それは真剣交えずに仕事なんですよ
だから分 二分であんたこういう風にしなさいというだけなんですね
一向にそういう風に自分の修行法っていうのを変えたくないんだからね
そうすると 仕事を教える側はもうもうバツを入れてます
リストからこの人はもうなかったことにしましょうと
それに対しても気がつかないんですね
見込みはなしと だから一回言ってやらなかったら
それでもうキリ ただ知りません
みんなこの指導者っていうのは甘いと思って甘くないんです
やるかやらないか それはもう生きるか死ぬかっていうぐらい死活問題のような感じで瞑想しないと
性格の問題は理性の問題でね
グニャグニャ状態では全然うまくいかない
だからカマッタナの場合はすごい厳しいんです
ではこうやりなさいと
ただ文句言わず そういう風にやらなくちゃいけない
仕事を与えたら仕事に文句言えますかね
仕事だから で それがうまくいかなかったら
それは別の話でやったんだけど
こんなことになり あんたダメや
この仕事はあんたに無理やと
こういう仕事しなさいと
それから別の仕事を与える
そこはもうカマッターナチャリアという指導者の仕事なんですね
だから瞑想を教えるお坊さんにカマッターナチャリアというんです
与える仕事にカマッターナというんです
このミャンマーから来るお坊さんたちに時々カマッターナチャリア
なんとか何とかと言ってるでしょうね
だからこの瞑想指導者っていう意味なんですね
それは仏教の用語で  覚えておいたっても構いません
そこでカマッターナってのはパーリ一般パーリ語で言えば仕事ということなんです
職業 そこで職業はつあります
複雑で複雑で うまくいかなかったらとんでもない大損をする
複雑で難しくて しかし
うまくいったら結果がある
それで単純明快ですが
うまくいったらまあ結果があって
うまくいかなかったら結果がないと
カタマンチャマナカマッターナマハッタンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナンマハサマランバンニッパジャマナンアッパッパランホーティ
第 一番目の説明 やることあまりにもありすぎ
しかし うまくいかなかったらとんでもない結果になる仕事って何なのかと
カシーコーマナ カシー
農業 田んぼの仕事 農業というのは大変難しい
複雑でいろんなことを判断しなくちゃいけない
当時の社会ではね 農業は簡単やと思ってます
そう簡単ではありません
会社で失敗する人々はどこかに行って
もう畑を借りて農業やったりするんですけど
もう生きるということは大変ですからね
植物もそう簡単じゃないんだから
ちょっと間違ったらもう何 1つもうまくいかないんだからね
人間の管理と同じことなんですよ
そこですごい動力 お金もかけて農業したんだけど
ちょっとでもうまくいかなかったら全部なくなってしまうんですね
あまりにも損しますよ
そこでものすごい仕事がありますが
うまくいったらかなり成功する
儲かる仕事って何なのかとお釈迦様が
カシーエバコーマナ それは農業ですと
そこら辺でわざと分析が単純化するんです
覚えやすくするために
違う仕事を出してもいいんですよ
例えば工業でもいいんですよ
武器を作る注文を受けたんだと
王様が戦争に出かけるんだと
あるいは北朝鮮に攻撃に行くんだそうと
それでもう武器をたくさん作りなさいと注文を出しちゃった
それで工業の人々はすごい大変な仕事でしょうね
でも全部売れればね すごい金儲かりますね
それで途中で注文取り消しと言われたらどうなるんですかね
それは第世界の国々に対してよくやることですよ
例えば 何か品物 小さなもの
日本にでも紹介しようと思ったら
これはいいものや これは儲かるんだぞと
一億円送ってちょうだい
一億個とかね 何万トンとかね
しかし 小さな工場でそんなことを作ってるって
そこでやっているところだから
いきなり一億と言えばね
これできない それで あらゆる機械をこちらから導入して
ものすごい もうそれで注文は出したんだけど
品物が遅いんだから取消しとかね
あるいは興味がなくなったとか
必ず途中で言うんですよ
言ったら あの人々っていうのはどれほど借金で損しているかというと
ものすごい恐ろしいんですね
こちらが機械を売って
それで儲かったんだから
それで終わっちゃうんです
それはよくあるんですよ
この国際経済世界ではね
で 先進国々にはもうわからない痛みなんですね
その上批判して終わっちゃう
こいつら怠け者 仕事をしないんだ
ただ自分たち何者かという
こちらでもほんのちょっとでも変えることできなくても
まあ十五年も苦しんでるんですけどね
で まあそう言っちゃいますけど
まあ日本でもどんな国でも同じことで
ですから 公表とか出してもいいんですよ
王様が戦争に行くんだから
槍やら盾やら作りなさいと
鍛冶屋さんに頼んだと
鍛冶屋さんがもうもう槍もう百万とかね
それを作ったり 盾はもう二千とかとか作ってる途中で王様が
いえ 戦争をやめたって言っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
だから他の仕事を出してもいいんだけど
そうするとこの論点がそれていっちゃいますね
頭があっちこっち行ってしまっちゃってね
だからこの理性とこの考え方がこの脱線しないで明確にまとめておきたいんですよ
そういうことで 例を出すときはいささく単純化する
複雑でややこしい仕事があります
うまくいかなかったらとんでもない損する
例えば農業 複雑でややこしい仕事があります
しかし うまくいったらものすごい良い結果になります
例えば農業と それでわかりやすいでしょ
わかりやすいでしょうと私が言いましたが
それでわかりますかね
わからないと思うんだったら
もう一度幼稚園に入れ直し
そういう単純ですよ 説明しません
それ以上は で 次にカタマンチャマナバというところ
これ上から数えると九行目からですね
カタマンチャマナバカンマッターナンアッパッタンアッパキッチャンアッパアディカラナンアッパサマーランバンニッパッジャマーナンアッパッパランホーティワニッジャコーマナラ
それで簡単単純明快な仕事はしかしうまくいかなかったら損する
それはどういう仕事かというと
ワニッジャ 商売 商売っていうのは簡単単純ですよと
しかし うまくいかなかったらかなり損する
で 商売っていうのは簡単単純ですから
仏教から見ればね それはまあ
どこかが誰かが作ってる品物を買って
他のところで高いお金で売る商売っていうのはそれぐらいのことですよ
複雑なものじゃないんです
そこで高いお金で売れれば儲かりますよ
もし売りに出た国で その品物の値段は自分買った値段より低いんだったらどうしますかね
もう商売にならないんですね
損してしまっちゃうんですね
そこで逆なこと 簡単単純な仕事でうまくいったらすごい得をする仕事って何であるかというと
ワニジャーイエバコマナ
それも商売ですよ そこでお釈迦様が次にたとえもうちょっとこれアプリケーションということで
この合わせてみるんですね
セイエタアピマナカシカンマッターナンマハッタンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナンマハサマーランバン
ヴィ
ッパジャマーナンアッパッパランホーティエメーバコーマニバガラアヴァーサカンマッターナンマハッタンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナンマハサマーランバンヴィッパジャマーナンアッパッパランホーティ
そこで あのたとえを当てはめてみせるんです
で 若者よ 農業というものはね
もうすごい仕事が多いんだと
土を作るところからもう刈り取るところまで大変複雑で多いんだと
しかし うまくいかないと
もうどうにもならない状態
でも一年間も食べるものなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
損は一年にわたってしまっちゃうんです
そのように 在家の生き方は農業のように大変複雑だよ
それで農業は在家の生き方にたとえてしまったんです
農業やる人と同じです
在家の生き方っていうのは
ものすごいやる仕事は多くて複雑で大変だよと
でも うまくいかなかったら全くも結果がない
そこで在家の人々 同じ在家の人々で
生き方は農業と同じくものすごい複雑でややこしいだと
しかし うまくいったらすごいいい結果が出てきますと
エーバメーバコーマナガラーヴァーサカンマッターナンマハッタンマハキッチャンマハーディカラナンマハサマーランバンサンパッジャマーナンマハッパランホーティ
って言われてそれでまあシタカラエバーナナギョーメカラですけど
セイエタアピマナワニッジャカンマッターナンアッパッタンアッパキッチャンアッパディカラナンアッパサマーラッバン
ヴィッパジャマーナンアッパッパランホーティ
例えば若者よ この商売というものは単純明快
楽々な仕事 しかし うまくいかないとものすごい想像を絶する損してしまう
もう借金してしまっちゃいますね
そのようにパッバッジャ出家という仕事
パッバッジャカンマッターナ出家という職業もアッパッタンアッパキッチャンすごい単純楽で
しかしうまくいかなかったらイッパッジャマーナン
間違ってしまえばアッパッパランホーティ
ほとんど結果がなく 借金で終わってしまっちゃう
赤字で終わってしまう
そこで同じく商売は簡単単純な仕事で
うまくいったらものすごい楽もしてすごい儲かる
うまくいったらそれをまた出家の職業ですね
そこでこの若者がこれわかったんですかね
おっしゃっていることは
この人はわかったんで負けたんです
お釈迦様間接的に言っていることはね
だからそこら辺は書いてない
とにかくどちらにするかと
だから問題はうまくやるかやらないかということなんですよ
上手に仕事をするかしないか
上手にするんだったら結果がありますよ
大儲けできます 大儲けできるかできないかということは
自分の生き方にかかってるんです
自分のやり方にかかってるんです
では 自分がしっかりやり方を知ってるんだったら
どちら選ぶんですかね
農業 商売 自分がものすごく儲かるんだったら
どんな仕事選ぶんですか？複雑な仕事
単純な仕事 単純な仕事選ぶでしょうね
当たり前な そんなこと
だから やり方さえ正しければ
出家の方がいいよ 何の欠片も言ってるんです
しかし 相手を侮辱することもなく
嫌な思いをさせることもなく
知恵を刺激させながら言ってる
言うんだよ 相手負けますよ
相手が負けるんだけど
もう嫌みとか悔しいとかね
こいつを殺してやりたい
そんな気持ちがなくて
さすがっていう感じになるんですよ
話し合いっていうのは
そういう風に持っていくんですよ
負けた相手はすぐ喜んでいるっていう状態
国際的な会談であろうが何であろうか
やはりそういう風に持っていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
でも人間には無理でしょう
こんなのは 根性はないし
理性はもうマイナスでしょうしね
頑張ろうという気持ちはないしね
だからこの知恵っていうのは
かなり頑張らないと出てこないんですよ
怠けちゃうとね ということで
かなり知恵 理性っていうのはすごく大事なことでね
一応あのまあ理想としてでも覚えておいてください
この話し合う場合は 会議やってる場合はいろんな異論が成り立ちますし
それで意見つがあるがあると
やっぱりOKになるのは実行になるのは一つだけでしょうしね
どうやって一つにするかと
その場合はもうややこしいかないか
結果はいかがなものかないか
そうやって長所短所いろいろ話し合って
これだったらこれがいいんじゃないかなと決めてしまうと
違う意見出した人は ああ
なるほど その通りですねと
なんのことなく 嫌な気持ちなく終わっちゃいますよ
一回意見決めたらそれで通さないと
また後でガチャガチャガチャ言っちゃうと
もう人間じゃないんですね
この間決めたことについてもう一つ意見がありますよと
もう人間失格で その場合はみんなで賛成で
みんなで賛成したならば
まあそれ以上はしゃべるなよと
仏教は厳しく言ってるんです
賛成する時は千人一致で賛成する
千人一致になるまでは過程が複雑かもしれませんだけど
とにかく千人一致になる
なった瞬間で黙れと それ以上しゃべるなと
しゃべっちゃうその人を追い出す
退場させちゃう 参加させない
ただの嫌な存在で迷惑だけ
だからそこら辺では厳しい
そこら辺では弱くて やっぱりもともともはっきりしているんだからね
理性の世界だから 知恵の世界だから
しっかりと癒すかどうかっていうところはもうはっきりしています
しかし 癒すかどうか決める道もそう簡単ではありません
一応ここのこの時点で釈尊がまあどちらでも五分五分だよと
うまくいけばもう大儲けできますよと
どんな仕事でも 在家のお仕事も出家の仕事でも
でも大儲けできるのは道が正しい時だけですよ
それだったら正しい道を歩んだ在家の人が大儲けしたとします
正しい道を歩んだ出家の人が大儲けしたとします
その二つ比べたら どちらの方がというと
簡単単純な仕事 出家の方がいっとも簡単で上なんですよ
でもそれは言ってないでしょ
教典の中に そこをわざと言うと相手に対して失礼ですよ
そういうところが繰り返してほしいところで
日本語で喋ってる時のあれじゃないんですね
日本では何回も繰り返してそれ言わないと頭に入らないんですよ
それはしない 仏教では結論は別にわざとは言わないんです
条件揃ってあげて いかがでしょうかと
こちらも結論出してないんですよ
ただ揃ってあげただけで
いかがでしょうかと そういうことで
まあバラモン若者がまあそれは置いておいてという感じで
もう次持っていくんですよ
これが楽じゃないじゃない
ブラーフマナボーゴと
次のポイントをあの若者が持っていくんですね
パンチャダンメパンニャーペンティ・プンニャッサ・キリヤーエ・クシャラッサ・アーラダナエ
同じポイントなんですね
プンニャッサ・キリアエ
徳を 徳行というか こう善行為するために
クサラッサ・アーラダナエ
善というもの 善いというものは体験するために
いわゆる精神世界で成功するために
徳を積んで 人間として精神的に成功するため
これ宗教の話なんです
別に世俗的な儲けの話じゃない
まあ世俗的な儲け話に例え出したんだけど
このバラモン人もお釈迦様も宗教の世界のことを喋ってるんです
きちんと そこ だから プンニャッサ・キリアエ
徳を積むために クサラッサ・アーラダナエ
善たるものを体験するために
バラモン人は五つのポイント
パンチャ・ダンマ 五つの法をパンニャーペンティ
設定しています これですと
パンニャーペンティっていうのは結論としてこれやりなさいと
例えば涅槃に至る道って何なのかと言えば
それが八正道であると設定しているんですね
そういうふうな感じで
そこで若者が五つの法
五つのポイントをバラモン人たちが設定していますと
善を獲得するために 善に至るために
と言ったら お釈迦様が
イエーテーノ・マハーバッハマナ・パンチャ・ダンメ・パンニャーペンティ・プンニャッサ・キリアエ・クサラッサ・アーラダナエ・サチェーテー・アガル・サードゥテ
ー・パンチャ・ダンメ・イマスミン・パリサン・バサッスーティ
それでお釈迦様がその善に至るために
善を獲得するために この設定している五つの法があるでしょう
サチェーテー・アガル
もしあなたに迷惑でなければ
アガルというのは苦しくはない
ガルっていうのは重いということ
アガルっていうのは重くない
軽いということで もしあなたに軽いであるならという
あなたに迷惑でなければ
サードゥ ありがたいと
テー・パンチャ・ダンメ
その五つの法をイマスミン・パリサティン・バーサス
このみんなに教えてあげてくださいと
五つの法ありますと言ったところで
ああそうですかということに行かない
お釈迦様は もしあなたによろしければ
みんなにその五つは何なのかと教えてあげてください
そこでバラモン人が ナコウ・メ・ボーゴータマ・ガル
あ それは私に別に難しいわけじゃありませんと
ヤッタス・バワントーワ・ニシンナ・バワンタ・ルーパーワ
あなたみたいな人の前で
そちらに座っているあなたみたいな人の前で
いわゆるあなたの前で
あるいはあなたのような方々の前で
そういうものを説明するのは決して難しくありませんと
というところは この相手がよく理解してくれるんだから
簡単単純に説明できるんですよ
テーナヒ・マーンワ・バサッス
それだったら言ってみなさいと
サッチャン・ボーゴータマ・ブラーマナ・パタマン・ダンマン・パンニャーペンティ・プンニャッサ・キリアエ・クサラッサ・アーラダナエ
一番目 サッチャン サッチャンというのは真実
これは道徳の世界だから真理ではありません
だから嘘つかないことですよ
英語で言えばトゥルース
だから真理ではなくて
事実というか トゥルースということですね
ワジー・サッチャン これ道徳の話ですから
あの真理の 論理 倫理の話
修行の話 精神の話だからね
すごく明確に意味が出現しない
だから軽々く まあ日本訳にしてもそれぞれ気をつけたことで
例えばこの功徳を積み
善を成就するという言葉は
まあそれでいいんですけど
それはまあずっと決まり文句で
まあいいことですけどね
一番目は真理 二番目 タパン
タパンというのはまあ苦行かな
で 苦行と訳していますけど
タパチャリアン やっぱりまあ修行ですね
何かちょっと大変なことをしてもらわないと
もうタパっていうのはまあ楽々な修行っていうのでもないんですね
まあインドの文化ではね
インドの世界ではタパンといえばね
まあ仕事をして家族を養っている生き方にはタパンと言わない
それはいくらか辞めて何かすることがタパンと言うんですよ
ですから出家もタパンですね
タパスという風になるし
必ずしも苦行でなければという意味でもないんです
ただ 在家として生活しないで
何か宗教的なことをする
その在家の仕事を辞める
家族の面倒見ることやら
それを一時的にしないで
家族から離れて 例えば一日二日間どこかにこもっているとかね
その時は苦行というか
タパスというんですね
修行中だとね ですから
修行というぐらいの意味ではいくらか通るんじゃないかなと思います
二番目は 3番目ブラフマチャリア
ブラフマチャリアというのはこれはバラモン人のことを言ってるんですよ
この場合は ブラフマチャリアっていうのは
まあ異性とは関係持たないという
まあ性行為っていうのはやめるという生き方なんですけど
それは仏教の定義で バラモン人の場合はかなり長い時間結婚してはいけないんですよ
で その間ではもう徹底的に宗教に入り込んで勉強するんですね
それはだいたい若い時ね
すごい小さい時も学校に入れちゃいますから
バラモン人のどこかに弟子入りさせますから
まあその分真面目に勉強終わるまで
まあ結婚とそんな思考さえも禁止なんです
一番厳しいんですよ 例えば十八
二十とかになってくると
まだまだ勉強して勉強終わってない場合は
異性に対する思考が入ったって
もうものすごい厳しく戒めるんですね
で 会わせませんし 見たってもえらい厳しく
今日先生と一緒に街に入りますけど
お前こういうこういうこと
こういうことをしてはいけないとかね
ものすごい厳しい だからその仕事をブラフマチャリアって言うんですね
もし街で女の人見て気に入ったならば
若者だからね まあこれですぐ分かります
先生はずっと子供の頃から面倒見ているんだから
これで厳しい罰を与えたりとかね
もう断食させたりとか
あるいはもう独房に入れたり
もういろんなことをさせて
もう立ち直ってもらうんですね
しかし 先生は結婚していますけどね
教える先生は それはもう学問終わってから先生はもう学問終わりました
それで必ずしも結婚しなくちゃいけない
それまた大変です で 学問終わったら
すぐ何か職業を見つけて結婚して家族を養うという修行しなくちゃ
それは修行なんですよ
子供を育てて大きくするという
その合間でもよろしいし
それは一旦一段落すると修行に入るという順番がありますね
バラモン人には 子供が一人前になってくると
もう親はもう再婚としての生活はもう一応やめる
やめて修行に入る そこがタパンということで
ブラフマチャリアっていうのは
この青年たちのもう学業ということだとは思いますね
それ 3番目ですね それでアジェーサナン
4番目アジェーサナン
アジェーサナンっていうのは学習ですよ
まあそれはね 知識を得ること
だからブラフマチャリアやってる間では学習はしますが
まあつこちゃで分けてます
これ 4番目 で 5番目 チャーガンコーボーゴートブラフマナパンチャナンダンマパンニャーペンティプンニャッサキリアヤクサラッサアラダナ 5
番目はチャーで与えること
お布施ですね そこでイメーパンチャダンメーパンニャーペンティプンニャッサキリアヤクサラッサアラダナヤティ
この 5つを教えているんだと
善行を成就するために
それで一番目は事実を語ること
いわゆる真理の人である
事実を嘘つかないこと
番目はタパン修行すること
三番目はブラフマチャリアン
性行為をやめること  四番目はアジェサナン
経典を挙げることですけどね
一応しきたりをこなすことなんですが
五番目はチャーガン与えること
イドバワンゴートモキンガ
それでお釈迦様何を思いますかと
そこでその人はものすごく綺麗にテーマを
上手 上手と言ったっても
すごくいい意味で ものすごい上手にテーマ変えるんですよ
サイケがよろしいか スッキがよろしいかというポイントをもう変えるんで
そこはもう二度と喋りません
次に もっと専門的に いわゆる前言ったのは
善行を成就するのはザイケのみ
それ崩れちゃったんです
そこで では善行を成就するために方法って何ですかと
我々は五つの方法を語っていますと
でお釈迦様の意見は何なのかと
そこでこの このバラモン人たちに
インドに他の宗教家たちにも全くもできなかった道を
そこからお釈迦様はもう伝えていくんです
で 世の中でこの偉いことをみんな言うんですよ
頭が悪い人に限って言うことはものすごいんですよ
こうやっ こうするべき
ああするべきとかね でもそんなのはほとんど根拠のない話で
例えば人間いうのはやっぱり嘘ついてはいけませんととかね
逆にアンタ知ってますかとかね
だからみんな他人に説教したりね
はしますが すごい美しい言葉並べて
それですごい人気もあるんですけど
仏教はそれすごくもういい加減にしなさいと
うるさいと という立場取ってるんです
だから特に道徳の世界では
人間何に感動するかっていうことは決まっていて
そこはもうペラペラペラペラ喋る
で 一番この道徳 倫理世界っていうのは擦れてるのはそういうわけなんですよ
いい加減みんな善悪を喋る
喋る時は徹底的にこうしてはいけません
必ずこうやるべきですとかね
そんなこと言ったっても
やれるかやれないかっていうこともはっきりしていないし
だから人にこうしなさいということっていうのは大変なことなんですよ
いい加減に言ってはいけませんしね
人の人生っていうのは人しかないんだから
それにした我々は他人に対しては
言う時は何でも言う 何だかんでも気楽に気楽に
もう言え 言えるところまで言う
それが仏教は徹底的に断る
そんなもう だから世の中の話なんかはほとんどゴミで見るんですね
例えば事実を語るべきですよと人が言ってきたって
もう仏教はあまり相手にしない
もう反対はできんところは知っていて攻撃してくるんですよ
突然 あんた盗む 私は盗むことを絶対認めません
あんたどう思いますか？と
言ったら 私も認めませんよと言わざるを得ないでしょうに
でも そういう愚か者の罠には仏教は嵌められません
よくあんた知ってますか？と
はっきりと うるさいことを言うなよと
という態度を取るんです
だからそこのポイントなんです
普通この この部分 下は全部カットして出しちゃうと
みんないきなり大賛成すると思います
この五つは素晴らしいと
で 仏教はそう単純じゃないんです
それで この五つとサイケ生活をどう当てはめるかと
そちらこれも説明していない
しかし バラモン人はサイケがその五つの働きをしなくちゃいけないということは
ブラフマ バラモン教でもう決まりです
あの四つの生き方があるんだと
バラモン人には ブラフマチャーリー
グリハスタ ヴァーナプラッスティ
サンニャーシーというね
その四つの生き方こちらで五つにして説明しています
だからそこら辺でも あの堂々とまるまるバラモン教の何々とか引用したかということはもうわからないようになってるんです
だから対照する比較する学者というのは大変です
わからないんです 例えば我の
あの アートマの説明はウパニシャッドにも入ってます
もうことごとく批判しています
しかしチャンドーギヤウパニシャッドのあの辺
ブラダラーナヤカのあの辺はこちらと合わないんだよとか
なかなか見出して発見することは鋭い学者でない限りはできません
だからこの五つはもうそれほど難しくないんですけど
バラモン人の四つの生き方を言っているところなんです
しかし もっと意味が深いね
こちらの場合は 言ってることはね
中身で言ってるんですよ
ただ 何歳から何歳まで結婚しないでいるかとか
そういう風には決めないんですね
口で形ではなくて 中身でこの若者は言っているんですよ
まず一生真理 真事実を語る人で
それからまあ奉行というかね
まあ結婚やめて頑張って学問をしてとか
で チャーガン 人を助けることも必要であると
お布施も必要であると
それでお釈迦様は本当はうるさいとお前はという態度で言ってるんですよ
そんな言葉ないんです
キンパナマーナ あんたどう思いますか？とお釈迦様は逆に質問します
あんたどう思いますか？アッティコーチブラームナナンエーカブラームノッピヨエヴァーハ
アハンイメーサンパンチャナンダンマナンアビンニャーサッチカットヴィパッカンパティーデーニ
君答えて どう思いますか？一人でも
バラモン人が一人でもいますか？一人で十分ということで
一人でいますか？こんなことを言ってる人が
アハン 私がこの五つの生き方
自分の知恵で 自分で経験して
自分で体験して こういう結果になりますよ
なりましたよという はっきりと自分で証拠を出す人が一人でもいますか？と
いわゆる人に言う前に
その道が正しいかないか
期待した結果に至れるかないか
自分で試してみてないと
信頼できません ただ 言葉がきれいだからとか
そんなのどうでもいいんです
例えばお布施するっていう
これ誰でもいい立派なことを言ってるんではない
仏教を見てますよと それだけのことで
あなた経験していますか？と
お布施することで ものすごくいい結果になるんだぞと
善は成就するんだぞと
私がやったんだから知ってますよと
そこなんです ポイントは
だからもうスリランカの言葉で言えば
狩人の説法みたいなもんでしょ
狩人が生命に優しくしなさいと説法すると
でもあいつは狩人なんですよ
誰がそんな話聞くんですかと
だから 言ってることは素晴らしい結果になりますよということは
言ってる人の責任なんですよ
言ってる人は指導者だから
人の人生と遊んではいけませんし
人間にとってはたった一回しかできんだからね
年はじりじりじりじりと取っていくでしょうに
だから畑でやるべきことは三十歳でできるわけないでしょうに
二十歳でやること二十歳でやるべきでしょう
だから時間というのは二倍にならないんだから
だからすごい気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからすごく気をつけて
すごい丁寧に すごく厳密に判断して
理性を持って生きていなくちゃいけない
二十歳でやるべきことを二十歳でやらなくちゃいけない
これで六十歳になった
あら 私はオートバイに乗ることできなかったんですよとかね
それでも遅いんだからね
[終始背景音楽]だからまあ
その その時間っていうのは
一秒っていうのは二回出てこないんですよ
そういうわけで 人にこうしなさい
ああしなさいというのはすごい大変なことで
危険なことじゃない で
私もかなり批判された一つのポイントなんですね
私はあんまりこの戒律なんかグチャグチャグチャグチャずっと言っていなかったんですね
それである一部私から勉強した一部が私に対してすごい反対
もう宗派作って あの人はもうとんでもないもう破壊野郎
戒律のこと何も言わないんだとかね
結局言ってることも私から教えてもらったものなんですけど
どこかから一言拾って
どこか外国行って直何か見てね
そんな無責任でね 私は責任があるんだから
そう簡単に言えませんよ
あんた嘘をつくなよと教からはと
言えますかね 人の人生だから
これどれほど心重いかということは
さっぱり仏教の世界以外の連中ってのはわかってないんです
何人か私にもう酒やめることを聞いたんです
私はやめなさいとはっきり言ってないんですよ
そんなすごい責任です
だから私は質問を変えてほしいんですね
仏教はどう見ているかと
そうすると 私は堂々と胸を張って
仏教ではこういうわけで
こういうわけで酒飲んではいけないんだと言ってますよと
だからあなたやめなさいと
それは私は絶対言いません
そんな責任持てません
だから私は酒をやめたいんですけど
あるいは酒やめてもよろしいでしょうかとかね
そんなのとんでもない質問なんですよ
自分のことくらい自分でやれと
自分の命だから しかし
逆に知識的に 何でお釈迦様はそんなに酒に酒に酔いて気が悪いんですかとかね
何て言いますか この敵に回してるんでしょうかとかね
そういう風に冗談交ぜで聞いたって
そうすると事実ですから
仏教の中身だから こういうことで仏教は酒は仏教と酒は飲めませんと
そういうデータだけは提供することはできます
それであなた個人的にどうですかと言えば
まあそれだったら自分の経験も言えます
しかし 相手には押し付けることはできません
私は一生酒を一滴も飲んだことはない
だからあなたも飲むなかれと言えますかね
五十六歳までずっと酒飲んで生きてきた人に
一生一滴も飲んでない人がどうやって言えるんです？そんなことは
ですから そこをどのように生きるべきかということは
これはもう自分の理性で判断するべきであって
判断するために必要なデータ
いくらでも提供する そういうことで
お互いに依存しないし
束縛はしないし 束縛はされませんし
自由で正しい道を歩める
例えば私が会社の社長なんか気を限りから嘘をつくのをやめなさいと言ったところで
その人 次の報告書を多分本物を本当のことを書いたところで
もうとんでもない もう何百億円も損しました
倒産しました 誰がその責任を持ちますかね
だからそこら辺は本人の責任で
こちらは正しいデータ
本当の情報を提供する
それが仏教の元々のやり方なんです
それ元々のやり方でやって
まあ批判しか私は受けてませんだけど
しかしそれは怒ってないんです
楽しいんです 一応こういうポイントになってくると
ちょっと説明しちゃいけないとおかないとね
だからこのポイントでそれわかるんでしょうしと思いますけどね
ただぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃしゃべるんじゃないんですよ
人に対しては どういう風に生きるべきか
何をするべきかっていうことはね
だからお釈迦様は聞くのは一人のブラマン人でもちゃんと実験して
これこそ正しいと 確実にこの結果に至るぞというふうに証拠を出してますか？と
結果は私は経験していますと
自分の経験で 一人もいますかと聞いたら
それはないと では 今のブラマン人たちは全然そこは自分で実験して
体験して 経験して この五つで善は成就できるんだときちんと分かったことはない
経験したこと まあいいんです
それで しかし そのバラモンたちの先生たちでも一人はいますかと
その先生たちの先生たち一人
パーチャリアというんですよ
まあそのアーチャリア・パーチャリアっていうのは
サンスクリットで言うとアーチャーリャ・プラーチャーリャになりますけど
大学に行ったっても 普通我々は助教授たちのところで勉強したりしますけど
まあ大教授もいますけどね
先生顔も見たことがないんですけどね
まあそんな感じで しかし
彼の力の下でみんな研究したりはいます
そんな感じで先生のところで教えてもらいますけど
その先生にもものすごい大先生はいるんですよ
大先生はまあパーチャリア・プラーチャーリャと言うんですね
パーリ語でパーチャリア
まあ一人のアーチャリア先生か
あるいは一人のパーチャリア先生でもいますかと
あるいはサッタマーアーチャリア言うが
あるいは代目まで遡ってでもいいんだよと
過去代目まで遡ってみたら
もう一番前の先生がそれ経験していても
一人だけでも十分ということなんですよ
たった一人だけ代目でもいいんです
先生の先生ではなくて
もっと前の先生 もっと前の先生
もっと前の先生でも これ発見して
自分で実践して実験して
自分でこのつの方で完全に前後を成就できるんだということを経験した人がいますかと代目までと聞くんですね
ノーヒダンボーゴーと
そんなことはないんだと
このヴェーダ聖典にそういう風にないということをお釈迦様は過去に知ってるんです
だから ブラフマン人よりお釈迦様はヴェーダ聖典はまあ最近のところは研究しているんです
覚えてるんです だからこの論理構成崩れてるところっていうのはよくよく知ってるんです
人の弱みを知ってる だから人は他人にお説教するだけで
自分で正しいかないか分かる
だって親が子供に嘘をつくななんて堂々と言うんだけど
この間お母さんが嘘ついたんではないかと言って反論すぐできるでしょうに
だからそんなのは無責任な説教ですよ
だから あまり教育っていうのはうまくいかないんですね
それでお釈迦様はこのヴェーダ聖典を人間に教えた
神の言葉聞いたという話がある
このヴェーダ聖典を構成した仙人の名前出すんです
イエービテーブラームナアナンプッバカーイッサヨ
一番あの開祖様でイッサヨっていうのは善人たち
仙人たち マンターナンカッターロ
マンタっていうのはヴェーダ聖典の言葉ですよ
パーリの場合はスッタと言いますね
教典という ヴェーダ聖典の場合はマンタ
マントラと言うんですね
カッターロっていうのは作成した人々
マンターナンパワッターロ
マントラは最初に唱えた後に渡した人々
イエサミダンエータリーブラームナポーラナンマンタパダンギータンパウッタンサンヒタン
タダヌガーヤンティ タダヌバサンティ
バシタンアヌバサンティ
ウワチタンアヌワチャンティ
それでお釈迦様からかっちゃうんです
今のバラモンたちを 一番昔
初期時代である仙人たちがこのマントラを作ったんですね
作って後の世代に渡したんですよ
そのマントラをエータライ
今頃ブラームナ バラモンたちがポーラナンマンタパダナ
遠い昔 一応ヴェーダ聖典出来てのは紀元前三千
四千あたりかもっと古いとも言ってるんだから
そこら辺のことを言ってるんですね
その昔のマントパダン・ギータン
これは歌なんですよ 結局
パウッタンは 歌を作成しているんですよ
サンヒタンというのはまたあの作成という文章作成
まあ歌の作成というサンヒタっていうのはあのエディションというか
このいろいろ十講にしましょう
十五にしましょうとかね
この名前を入れましょうとか
一応編集過程なんです
サンヒタンというのは
それをアヌガーヤンティ
昔のガーヤティっていうのは歌うこと
だからお釈迦様は歌でしか見てないんですよ
ヴェーダ聖典を ただの歌だと
だから昔の先人たちがそれを歌った
あなた方はアヌガーヤンティ
それに沿って今歌っている
アヌバーサンティ 喋る
昔の先生たちが喋った通り
今あなた方は後継いで喋る
バハシタンアヌバーサンティ
ワーチタンアヌワーチャね
昔言ったことは今後継いで言ってるんだよと
だからからかってもあなた方はね
昔の先生たちのに後継いで今歌ってるでしょ
喋って勉強してる そのヴェーダ聖典を作ったあの先人たちが
遠い昔の先人たちが 彼らが何なのかと
それで名前を言っておかないと
お釈迦様知ってることになりませんからね
セイヤティーダン 例えばアッタカ
ワーマカ ワーマデーワ
ウェッサーミッタ ヤマタギー
アンギーラサ バーラッドワージ
ワーセット カッサパ バグ
十人いるんです サクセッサーが
確かに でもインド文化圏文化世界では大変なもう尊い人と思われる人々で
その家柄も 例えばワーセットバラモンたちはすごい格が高い
直系だから バーラッドワージバラモンというものすごいインドでお釈迦様の弟子になったんだけど
後で もう直系だから格が高い
テーピエワマハンと 彼らさえでもいいんだから何かを言ってますかと
私たちがこの五つの方で前後上下できると体験していますよと
そうするとノーヒダンボーゴーと
違いますと その人々も言ってない
言ってないんだから その人々そんな五つの方
喋ってもないんですよ
そこまでお釈迦様 ヴェーダになってくると
こんなブラフマチャリアとかタッパとか全然ないんです
チャーガとか全くもない
でもこの人々は自分の聖典はこの十人の先人たちが構成
神様から聞いて構成しましたと言っていて
偉大なる絶対的な権力
権力 権威を与えているんですよ
しかし そちらにはこの五つの方が書いてないんです
書いてないっていうことは別な話で
これはお釈迦様は裏で知ってるんだから
書いてないってこと だから言うわけじゃないんで
とにかく でもポイントは成り立ちます
その先人さえも言ってない
その先人さえも経験していないってことだけは確かなんです
イティキラマナ それだったら若者よ
ナッティコーチブラフマナーンエーカブラフノーピヨーエワマハン
一人もブラフマン人もこれこそ正しいと経験していない
先生たちも経験していない
先生の先生たちも経験していない
知らない 七代目まで聞いたっても知らない
そんなどころか 先人十人の先人たち
このヴェーダ聖典を構成した先人たちさえも
私たちが自分で実験して経験して正しいとわかってるんだよとは言ってないんだよと
セイヤターピマナワアンドウェーナウェーニパランパラサンサッタ
これがこの盲の人々の繋ぎ
チェーンですよだよと
目が見えない人はずーっと並んでるだけではない
ウェーニっていうのはこの目が見えないんだから
前の人の手か杖か繋ぎ捕まってますよ
しかし ずーっと並んでみんな目が見えない
プリモーピネパッセティ
一番前にいる人も目が見えない
マッジモーピネパッセティ
真ん中にいる人々も目が見えない
パッチモーピネパッセティ
ノーパッセティ 一番最後の人でも見えない
ですから 目が見えない人はもう百人並べていたっても
一人だけでも目が見えるんだったら
もうなんとか無事歩けますよ
いたって見えない エワメーワコーマナワアンドウェーヌトゥママンニェブラフマナーンバシタンサンパジェティ
あんたバラモンたち言うことはこのアンドウェーヌ
この目が見えない人のチェーンというかな
連鎖みたいなもんだよと
それでこの若者キレちゃったんです
今まで落ち着いてた もう徹底的に潰しちゃった
で キレるのお釈迦様これも期待しているんですが
その人はいいことを言ったんですよ
この事実を語るやら 性行為をやめて頑張ることをやら
修行することやら 勉強することと
また布施をすること 五つとちゃんと誰でも反対しないものを言ったのに
誰でもすごいいいことやと
今も日本の学者たちがね
インド人のこの四つの生き方というのは素晴らしいことやと
もう学説まで書いているでしょうに
すごい世間で誰でもいいと思ってることを言ったのに
これ お釈迦様はそれだけはもうとことん落としちゃうんですよ
だから なんでこの差は？サイキが偉い
修行が偉いけど お釈迦様そういうもん軽々とあまり気にしないですごく優しく間接的に言っていて
全然相手を攻撃しなかった
でもはっきりと道徳生き方になってくると徹底的に潰すという
だからいかに大事かと
生き方っていうのは 我々はどのように生きるかっていうことを無責任で言うなよと
もう確かにお釈迦様も嘘つくなかれと徹底的に真理のみ語れとは言ってますよ
でも だからといってそんないい加減な人の話には乗らない
無責任の話には乗らない
たとえ良いことを言っても
その人は自分の生活でそれを実験していないと
実行していないと相手にしてはいけないんです
騙されます 日本ではもうこれはもう何百回も経験しているでしょうに
神様たちは次から次へと現れるでしょう
悟っている人を次から次へと現れるでしょう
最終解脱者もいくらでも現れるでしょう
もうお釈迦様の生まれ変わり
至る所に私が釈迦の生まれ
私が釈迦の生まれ変わりとかね
それは日本独特の現象で
もう最高のものにしか目が行かないんですね
で 実際の生き方何なのかというと
ちょっとした単純な理屈も理解しないというかね
単純な道徳さえも理解しないし
未だに私にはこの慈しみは正しいってことを説得できなかったんだから
もう15年にわたって
あれほど単純明快の教えさえも
だから理解能力はそれぐらいなんですけど
ブッダたちがいるわ もう神様たちがいるわという
だからただ言っただけで乗るなよと
人に修行させるというとんでもないことでしょうに
若者 君やりなさい 君やりなさいとかね
自分でやって人に言うものでしょうに
だから どれほど社会が迷惑か
社会に迷惑かけるか 危険になるか
日本人全体的に宗教に対して
精神的なことに対してみんな嫌いでしょうに
だからみんな地獄に行くように道案内していたのは誰ですかというと
私じゃないんですよ 日本人っていうのは全体的に宗教嫌いでしょうに
それはもう昔からそんなものじゃないでしょうに
昔から日本文化っていうのはすごい道徳を重んじる
宗教も重んじるという民族でしたでしょうに
お寺っていうのは当たり前で
もう修行に行くのは当たり前で
日13半時のことをお花祭りやるわ
もういろんなもう涅槃会とかなんとかってやるわ
お盆もやるとかね もうあらゆることをもう仏教と一緒になってやってて
これはもう絶対宗教だったらもう煙たがって
もう煙たがって絶対嫌ってことになったのは何なのかと
それは西洋の影響 アメリカの影響で
それは私はあまりそれはそうではないとは思いますね
アメリカ人もすごい宗教には興味ある
いい加減じゃないんです
アメリカ人は宗教やめなさいと一度も言ったこともない
もっと遊びとは言ってるんですけど
それは別に 道徳を犯せと寺を壊せとは言ってないんです
そういう人々は さらに再評価してくれるしね
日本文化を ですから 決してそれはヨーロッパやアメリカの影響でもないんですよ
だから このすごい戦争終わって時からもう
もうものすごいインチキ的なデタラメな人々が出てきて
日本社会をめちゃくちゃにしてしまったんですね
その傷っていうのはものすごいもんで
なかなか治らないんですよ
だから冗談じゃないんです
この偉そうなお説かいというか
お説教というか あれやれこれやれというのは
だからこの時点でも仏教は厳しい
前よりはマシなことを言ってるのに
二番目のセットでこの若者が
前のことは何よというぐらいのバカバカしさ
でもそこら辺ですごい親切でしょうし
優しいでしょうし マシなこと言ったところで
ものすごいあんた方はもうただの目が見えない人々の
何といいますか 連中だと
どこに歩いてるんだろう
もし誰かが前の人の末と一番後ろの人の末つながっちゃうはどうなるんですかね
みんな歩く 前の人知ってるんだぞと思って
前の人 みんな同じところでぐるぐる回るだけで
そうすると それはブラインドサークルというのは
人々みんな目が見えない人々が一つの輪になったような感じです
それっていうのは綺麗に捨てたって考え方
全くもう否定しちゃったんです
釈迦尊という時は そこはお布施は良くないとは言ってない
あの欲を止めることは良くないけど
それも言ってないんです
修行することは やめない
ポイントに対しては別に何も文句言ってないんです
問題はそのポイントは実行しているかないかとか
それでまあそう言われたら
灯台さんがものすごく怒るんですね
そこから次の勉強会で進めます
[終始効果音]